asma mala experte en économie des
plateformes maître de conférences à
sciences po paris fondatrice de l'objet
de sa plainte society bonjour à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france d'abord sur ses mesures de
rétorsion de la part de washington de
nouvelles sanctions contre des produits
français
comment justement accueillir ces mesures
en réalité ce qui est en train de se
jouer c'est d'abord fin elle se situe
d'abord essentiellement sur un plan
symbolique puisque ce qu'on voit en fait
apparaître depuis quelques temps dans
l'économie mondiale est dans la posture
américaine c'est plutôt une position
d'un positionnement extrêmement
protectionniste est très protecteur de
leur industrie stratégique et donc
notamment les nouvelles technologies en
particulier les gars femmes
donc en ce sens n'est pas du tout les
lubies qu'on pourrait croire d'un train
de complètement fou mais c'est une vraie
stratégie commerciale aujourd'hui qui
est protectionniste d'une part des
marchés intérieurs et des et des grandes
et des grands secteurs stratégiques
américains d'une part et puis par
rapport au marché mondial
une attitude qui est pour le coup
extrêmement hégémonique expansionniste
donc en ce sens la décision des états
unis d'abord de se retirer des accords
de l' ocde
il y a qu il y à un mois de ça et
ensuite aujourd'hui de de menacer en
fait de rétention n'est absolument pas
du tout étonnant suspendu l'a justement
c'est un bras de fer auquel on s'attend
puisque bruno le maire entend cas dans
son entourage et lui-même affirme que la
seule issue possible c'est un accord
dans le cadre justement dalle ocde
alors ce qui est ce qui est toujours un
tout petit peu gênant avec la position
de la france d'une part et de l'europe
d'autre part c'est que en réalité quand
on vous dit bras de fer mais les
rapports de force sont déjà extrêmement
déséquilibrée et pour qu'il y ait un
rapport de force il faut il aurait il
aurait fallu qu'il y ait en fait un un
équilibre dans dans l'est dans les
différentes positions et là le discours
où la posture de bruno le maire et en ce
sens contradictoire que henry
évitez quand il ya eu les premières
négociations aux singles ocde et qu'on
était à deux doigts de trouver ce fameux
accord d'harmonisation fiscale qui
aurait évité toutes les possibilités de
dumping fiscal dégâts femme est bien à
deux doigts de trouver cet accord là les
etats unis se sont rétractés précisément
pour les raisons que je vous expliquais
c'est à dire une posture aujourd'hui en
économie en commerce international qui
est plutôt très protectionniste de la
part des états unis et qu'on retrouve de
façon absolument symétrique d'ailleurs
en chine puisqu'on a aujourd'hui deux
blocs qui en fait sont en train de
rééquilibrer tout l'échiquier
géopolitique américains d'une part
chinois d'autres pas avec des postures
extrêmement protectionnistes et à la
fois expansionniste parce
qu'objectivement on peut imaginer que
les gars femmes en ont les moyens de
payer finalement cette taxe ils ont
absolument vous avez parfaitement raison
ils ont absolument les moyens de la
payer et en ce sens de toute façon on ne
fait pas de la régulation internationale
avec juste la france tout seul qui va
prendre 100 millions d'euros ça n'a
strictement aucun sens et c'est encore
une fois pour ça que je disais que
c'était une mesure d'abord symbolique et
qui en fait envoyé un signal les états
unis envoient un signal fort on ne joue
pas avec les les secteurs stratégiques
américains et puis il envoie un signal
beaucoup plus général qui aujourd'hui
dans plutôt du conflit commercial et
puis des guerres commerciales dans
lesquels en tout cas face à l'europe
ils sont plutôt partie gagnée alors que
va faire la france le fonds monétaire
international exhorte à un accord
international pour résoudre justement ce
conflit ce que la france pour revenir
sur ses intentions cette taxe a bien
femmes elles pourraient d'autant que
souvent en réalité le nom espèce de
réflexe pavlovien sur la taxe comme
comme mesure de rétorsion comme mesures
de régulation première
là où en réalité on aurait pu voir
explorer d'autres pistes un peu plus
proactive un peu positif de l'ordre de
la régulation des données personnelles
et c'est donc de ce point de vue là et
par principe et en théorie on pourrait
n'empêche que il me semble que le
gouvernement français et bruno le maire
à plusieurs reprises a exprimé aussi des
positions de principe et d'ego et donc
ça me semble extrêmement difficile
pendu vraiment de la psychologie même
dieu de l'exécutif de rétropédaler
puisqu'on a tout un discours et toute
une posture retour de la souveraineté en
réalité qui est surtout essentiellement
de la rhétorique politicienne dans ce
sens merci à vous ce malade je rappelle
que vous êtes expert dans l'économie des
plates formes maître de conférences à
sciences po et fondatrice de los angels
aussi à bien des sociétés merci m